Carrusel de las artes
[Música]
María Carolina piña
Hola
reciban un cordial saludo desde París un
placer que esté en una vez más en
nuestra sintonía comenzamos ya mismo
Este programa en el que haremos una
excursión por los océanos el cine y la
música francesa
un viaje hacia las profundidades del
océano y sus maravillas vivientes Esa es
la invitación que hace el fotógrafo
francés Alexis y su proyecto One Ocean
que busca explorar documentar y
preservar la riqueza de los océanos
conversamos con el director de cine
chileno Patricio Guzmán quien estrena en
Francia su último documental mi país
imaginario sobre el estallido social de
2019 en Chile
una comedia sobre el mundo de la
pospandemia y una historia de amistad y
de amor en los estrenos del cine francés
y francófono y con nosotros también el
carismático cantante francés giannik Noa
quien exhorta disfrutar del presente en
su último álbum porque como él dice la
vida es ahora
[Música]
Carrusel de las artes los lleva hoy a
explorar los fondos marinos a través del
lente de Alexis El fotógrafo y buzo
francés presenta su proyecto fotográfico
y científico llamado One Ocean que busca
mejorar nuestros conocimientos de los
océanos nos amplía Melissa barra
un azul profundo abismal en el queco
habitan en armonía peces corales y
mamíferos las fotografías de Alexis
rosenfells no sumergen en los océanos o
más bien en un solo y mismo océano One
Ocean que el mundo entero debe proteger
bueno yansajos Juan Ocean es un proyecto
que durará 10 años un proyecto de
exploración que lanzamos con la UNESCO
Vamos a viajar por todo el mundo para
contar historias y así explicar lo
importante que son las exploraciones
para la ciencia porque es a través de la
ciencia y podremos resguardar lugares
excepcionales
[Música]
Cómo serán los océanos a lo largo de la
década de los años 20 desde la Polinesia
francesa o las Islas Elias en
italiano
que prácticamente vimos nacer en el sur
de la Polinesia y que podamos
cada día se acercaba más a mí y nos
volvimos amigos hasta que sus muestras
de efecto Se volvieron demasiado
peligrosas y tuve que poner fin a esos
momentos que pasó la ballena con su
fotógrafo favorito
comenzó el proyecto con la fundación
onenotion en 2021 y a fotografiado las
riquezas y las maravillas del mar pero
también lo que lo amenaza
después vamos a mostrar especies
invasivas o invasoras vamos a ver
reservas naturales y cuán importantes
son esas áreas marinas protegidas para
el mundo y para la humanidad veremos
también lo crucial que son los arrecifes
coralinos y Cómo podemos movilizarnos
para proteger ese ecosistema que el
calentamiento global ha deteriorado La
idea es que podamos decir todos podemos
actuar para proteger el medio ambiente
actuemos el océano así son
de aquí a 2030 Alexis rosenfell planea
presentar mil fotos en distintas
muestras en Francia
y de los océanos vamos al séptimo arte
el conocido y apreciado director de cine
chileno Patricio Guzmán estrena en
Francia su último documental mi país
imaginario el autor de la nostalgia de
la luz el botón de nácar o La cordillera
de los sueños continúa así su
exploración de la historia reciente de
su país estaba su cámara se enfocó en
las razones y esperanzas generadas tras
el estallido social de 2019 en Chile
[Música]
el 18 de octubre de 2019
un estallido social encendió Chile
Patricio Guzmán ha dedicado su vida a
explorar con el cine la historia de su
país antes durante y después del golpe
de estado y la dictadura militar esta
vez enfocó su objetivo en las protestas
masivas que se produjeron en Chile en
2019 por una vida mejor Salud Educación
y una nueva constitución
era increíble Porque primero había
piedras había tantas piedras como
pavimento era inmenso y toda la gente
con una piedra en la mano enfrentando a
la policía en una una cosa insólita o
sea no eso no ocurría en Chile hacía
mucho tiempo y la gente se organizó
también de una manera espontánea no
había organizaciones tradicionales había
grupos que se conectaban y era muy
interesante era interesante ver la rabia
que tenía toda esa gente para protestar
Patricio Guzmán dedica en este
documental un espacio central a la
violencia policial contra los
manifestantes y a la epidemia de heridos
oculares la policía es muy violenta dis
el cuerpo dispara de cerca balas
lacrimógenas que son muy duras y a los
ojos eso al principio era muy brutales
después bajaron un poco la violencia
cuando vieron tantos heridos pero se
quedó mucha gente sin ojos o sea fue una
represión brutal
que no se puede curar O sea la gente
quedó tuerta o ciega insólito hoy día la
esperanza le ganó al miedo mi país
imaginario explora también diversas
aristas de la situación política y
social chilena Y en especial la lucha
feminista
esta salida va a ser con rostro y con
voz de mujer casi todas las
entrevistadas son mujeres a excepción
del presidente de la república hablan
mejor son más claras tienen argumentos
son más luchadoras y son están
organizadas las demandas de la revuelta
son feministas también las mujeres
cuando hubo desaparecidos al principio
cuando pinochet que ellas tomaron
conciencia se organizaron hicieron
comités
grupos de ayuda salieron a viajar por
todo el país Buscando los muertos
digamos la mujer tomamos la iniciativa
desde el comienzo de la represión es muy
bueno el papel de la mujer en Chile es
interesante
[Música]
pasamos ahora a nuestro bloque dedicado
a los estrenos del cine en francés y en
la basta oferta de nuevas películas
destacamos la primera comedia francesa
poscovid y una tierna historia de
amistad y amor filmada en Bélgica
Cómo son las relaciones tras la pandemia
del coronavirus como hemos cambiado y
Qué nuevas manías hemos adoptado de esto
habla esta cinta francesa el mundo de
después
el mundo de después presenta nueve
veladas paralelas que transcurren en un
edificio parisino los protagonistas
hablan de diversos temas sobre todo de
la crisis sanitaria y de sus
consecuencias Pero también de otras
situaciones que han marcado la
actualidad francesa como son la lucha
feminista o el islam el resultado son
conversaciones a veces ácidas a veces
duras Pero todo con mucho humor
es esa
Yo también de Bélgica llega esta
película luminosa y entrañable Close
cinta premiada con el gran premio del
festival de cine de canness
primer lugar
[Música]
es la historia de amistad entre Leo y
Remmy dos adolescentes de 13 años
inseparables hasta que un comentario
malintencionado resquebraja el lazo que
los une el director de esta cinta Lucas
dondt
Todos hemos tenido nuestra vida
amistades que nos han marcado o hemos
sufrido con amigos que cambian o que
perdemos pero cuando se habla de
corazones rotos es casi siempre para
referirse a las relaciones amorosas y No
necesariamente cuando se trata de amigos
yo quise Mostrar eso en esta película
[Música]
ahora ya de presentarles a una figura de
la escena musical francesa como siempre
de la mano de Natalia Olivares Hola
Natalia y hoy nos presentas a un
cantante conocidísimo súper apreciado en
Francia y que se dio a conocer hace casi
40 años no en la música sino en las
canchas de tenis y él se llama Jenny de
las personalidades preferidas de los
franceses primero porque fue el último
francés en haber ganado el gran slam
wong y también por su gran carrera
musical que lo llevó a fabricar 12
álbumes y nos habla ahora mismo de la
mafe el último
la mafe sea
marfe era un lugar importante para mi
madre y lo recordaba siempre cuando
vivía en África ese lugar estaba en
Francia le sartén la región donde nació
me acuerdo que cerraba los ojos y desde
África donde hacía calor 45 grados
podía reconectarse con su naturaleza con
la primavera el otoño la lluvia los
caracoles las presas silvestres y más fe
es el nombre de mi último álbum que es
un pequeño homenaje a mi mamá mamá
[Música]
La mamá de yanick Noa era pues francesa
y su papá Camerún es baktua África otro
single de este álbum habla de esas
raíces
[Música]
la clásica
volver a África es la idea de volver a
la infancia me fui de allí demasiado
temprano salía los 12 años con un
billete de ida no tuve retorno pasé 50
años desarrollando mi lado Francés pero
mireme la cara por supuesto soy africano
y me enviaron energías desde África como
a cualquier otro africano pero yo no
había explorado ese lado mío tuve que
volver y el tiempo allí lo necesitaba
pero no me había dado cuenta hasta que
se me hizo obvio volver o regresar entre
comillas o irme es un pasaje de vuelta a
los lugares de la infancia África se
siente también volver a caer de pies
con hombres
[Música]
no Así dice la canción La vida es ahora
ya hay que decirlo conoció los altos de
la gloria y Los bajos de la depresión y
todas esas lecciones debidas la comparte
en este álbum la mafe
Raúl no he ido a la escuela luché con
una raqueta y hoy tengo un micrófono
Claro que hay angustia y yo canto en las
cárceles tengo asociaciones y sé que a
la hora que hablamos hay familias que se
están ahogando en el Mediterráneo porque
buscan la libertad Pero estoy aquí
contigo y sé que yo soy un privilegiado
y no tengo derecho a decir que las cosas
van mal tengo que decirte que van bien
soy una persona sensible pero la vida es
bella porque tenemos la suerte de estar
vivos
[Música]
gracias Natalia Olivares por
presentarnos a ese y enigno ay con ese
positivismo y energía africana del que
él nos habla vamos a despedir Este
programa Carrusel de las artes va a
actuar África de yannick Noa Muchísimas
gracias por su sintonía y hasta la
próxima
[Música]